there's a lot of men and women who have
a midlife crisis at 40 that didn't
happen to you well I'm still playing I
know my boss rkk says that all the time
- yeah he does he says most men either
changed their wife where their job you
know in their 40s and I said well not me
so I still get to play football and I
still love my wife so very much yeah
no no midlife crisis for you your father
famously
promoted your career from very early on
how much credit do you give him for for
your success so much I mean my dad is
when I grew up I mean I had three
sisters and I adored my sisters but I
was always the baby brother and my dad
you know being his only son you know he
was always like hey let's go you know
hit some golf balls or you know and I
was always tagging along so he was
someone I always looked up to I still do
today and he's been such a supportive
person in my life for you know my entire
career and he has made so many efforts I
think about your grow up in California
and I had a couple schools in california
recruit me to play in in college but I
chose Michigan so here he was flying to
the East Coast to watch me play and then
you get drafted by the Patriots and
apply further east you know he's he's
racked up a lot of frequent flyer miles
he and my mom traveling to watch me play
and being supportive and being there too
you know when they see me come off the
field you know to hug me and give me a
kiss and tell them tell me that they
love me and you know I just had the best
parents and I've been able to share in
so many of these great you know seasons
with them so how's your mom doing she's
doing good she's doing really good she's
you know it's what a battle she spot and
you know inspiration comes in many ways
and she's been a big source of
inspiration for me she's the most loving
caring sweet person and you know in the
world and you know so many people were
there to support her when she really
needed it and I'm happy she's doing
really great and she's gonna be here at
the opener against Kansas City and you
know it was really nice to see her at
the Super Bowl yeah that was big I mean
it was really big
she wasn't feeling great that week and
we weren't sure if she was gonna be able
to make it and she really came through
she wanted to be their first son and so
it was great and I understand mr. Kraft
had a special gift for her yeah he got
her a ring and surprised her it was so
sweet he's like do you think you know
what do you think about this for Mom
and I said I said that's incredible
gesture you know to think of her in that
way and he says you know she was with us
all year and you know she again provides
those inspiration that we needed to at
certain points in it's so sweet it says
Galen and there's a big heart on it and
so we're very proudly so your mom is
walking around with a big Super Bowl
ring I know it's totally not like her I
mean anyone who knows my mom like I'm
sure she's got it to show her friends if
she needs to but my dad on the other
hand always wears his super ring I gave
him a Super Bowl ring at my in 2001 I
gave him my Super Bowl ring and you know
he gets to wear it a lot but it was much
more understated in 2001 and mr. Kraft
the size is probably doubled since that
time once you win that many Super Bowls
he gets another diamond Super Bowl ring
right the first one was great it was
like appropriately sized and now he's
just gone and you know they're really
trophies so they're hard earned and you
know every person who wins one you know
should be very proud to wear it it's a
big accomplishment